Lucia: 谢谢
Lucia: Thanks.
Lucia: 先把这个形状画出来嗯底下那个
Lucia: First, let's draw this shape, yeah, the one at the bottom.
Jake: 换了个脸型
Jake: Changed the face shape.
Jake: 整容大整容
Jake: Major plastic surgery.
Lucia: 对然后我从后面再画五官
Lucia: Yes, then I'll draw the features from the back.
Lucia: 但我觉得现在这个反正定位还行
Lucia: But I think the positioning is okay for now.
Lucia: 好所以我先剪下来试试
Lucia: Alright, so I'll cut it out and try it.
Lucia: 但是其实我最开始的那个它才是
Lucia: But actually, the first one I did was the right size.
Lucia: 它才是合比例的大小
Lucia: That one was the right proportion.
Lucia: 所以我现在有点虚
Lucia: So I'm a bit unsure now.
Jake: 没事很多板
Jake: It's okay, we have plenty of boards.
Lucia: 没事还可以再画一点对
Lucia: It's alright, I can draw some more, yeah.
Jake: 最不缺板
Jake: Boards are the least of our worries.
Lucia: 希望这个定位是准的
Lucia: I hope this positioning is accurate.
Lucia: 然后再在上面
Lucia: Then I'll...
Lucia: 我在我就可以用白板笔了嗯
Lucia: I can use the whiteboard marker on top, yeah.
Lucia: 要不然的话还得
Lucia: Otherwise, I'll have to...
Lucia: 呃我稍等一下啊
Lucia: Uh, wait a second.
Lucia: 我想把这个先解开
Lucia: I want to untie this first.
Lucia: 看看他的大小和定位符合不
Lucia: To see if the size and positioning match.
Lucia: 符合的话这个稿子就可以投入生产了
Lucia: If they match, this draft can go into production.
Tasha: 要尝一个吗
Tasha: Want to try one?
Tasha: 好
Tasha: Okay.
Jake: 我先把这个先冲掉
Jake: Let me rinse this off first.
Tasha: 除了通这个别的我都完成了
Tasha: Other than clearing this, I've done everything else.
Tasha: 我说除了通这个水之外别的我都干了
Tasha: I mean, other than clearing this water, I've done everything else.
Jake: 好
Jake: Okay.
Tasha: 要吃吗
Tasha: Want to eat?
Lucia: 嗯 可以吃了吗
Lucia: Hmm, can we eat now?
Tasha: 是的
Tasha: Yes.
Lucia: 稍稍等我等会把这弄完
Lucia: Just a moment, let me finish this.
Lucia: 洗个手谢谢薇薇
Lucia: Let me wash my hands, thanks, Tasha.
Tasha: 那我就要放到这里了
Tasha: Then I'll just put it here.
Jake: 薇薇做狗吗
Jake: Tasha, are you making a dog?
Tasha: 不做
Tasha: Not doing it.
Jake:不做狗
Jake: Not being a dog.
Jake: 我就两条看门狗
Jake: I just have two guard dogs.
Jake: 哈哈哈刚刚好
Jake: Hahaha, just perfect.
Tasha: 哦靠
Tasha: Oh, damn.
Jake: 就 是吗
Jake: Right?
Tasha: 太过份了
Tasha: That's too much.
Jake: 就是别人家里面是俩石狮子
Jake: Other people have stone lions at their doors.
Jake: 咱俩看门狗
Jake: We have two guard dogs.
Lucia: 果然在我把它修成这个大小之后
Lucia: Sure enough, after I trimmed it to this size,
Lucia: 他可能稍微有点点小
Lucia: It might be a bit small.
Jake: 这是什么品种
Jake: What breed is this?
Lucia: 管他什么品种
Lucia: Who cares about the breed.
Lucia: 哈哈
Lucia: Haha.
Lucia: 我已经放弃专门搞一个品种出来了
Lucia: I've given up on getting a specific breed.
Jake:好嘞
Jake: Got it.
Lucia: 因为你要画的很那什么的话
Lucia: Because if you want to draw it really well,
Lucia: 我得用铅笔弄个稿
Lucia: I have to sketch it out with a pencil first.
Tasha: 好烫啊这个的话
Tasha: This is so hot.
Tasha: 你干嘛要拿这个纸
Tasha: Why are you using this paper?
Jake: 拿这个纸擦一下
Jake: To wipe it up.
Jake: 里边
Jake: Inside.
Tasha: 哦这可以
Tasha: Oh, this works.
Tasha: 这个纸是我昨天在京东刚买的
Tasha: I just bought this paper on JD yesterday.
Jake: 好嘞
Jake: Got it.
Tasha:我就是告诉你一下
Tasha: Just letting you know.
Jake: 我靠看起来是正的
Jake: Wow, it looks right.
Jake: 啥意思啊
Jake: What does it mean?
Tasha: 宠物宠物殡葬师
Tasha: A pet funeral director.
Lucia: 身体把这个字都翻到里面更好
Lucia: It would be better if the body flipped this character inside.
Lucia: 但是
Lucia: But,
Lucia:我觉得我已经懒得翻了
Lucia: I think I'm too lazy to flip it.
Lucia:就这样吧
Lucia: Let's just leave it.
Alice:你用完了吗
Alice: Are you done with it?
Lucia: 啊你用吧
Lucia: Ah, go ahead.
Lucia: 谢谢
Lucia: Thanks.
Lucia: 先这样
Lucia: For now.
Lucia: 看看背面这个定位现在行不行
Lucia: Let's see if this alignment on the back works.
Lucia: 定位行我就投影到正面去
Lucia: If it does, I'll project it to the front.
Jake: 我可算想起来刮胡子了啊
Jake: Finally, I remembered to shave.
Tasha: 啊
Tasha: Ah
Jake: 我可算想起来了
Jake: I finally remembered.
Tasha: 想起来什么
Tasha: Remembered what?
Jake: 把胡子刮了
Jake: To shave my beard.
Tasha:哇
Tasha: Wow
Tasha: 等会就有最需要你的活了啊
Tasha: Soon there'll be a job that really needs you.
Jake: 什么搅和
Jake: What kind of job?
Jake: 打蛋液
Jake: Beating eggs.
Jake: 打奶油
Jake: Whipping cream.
Tasha: 拉拉面团
Tasha: Kneading dough.
Jake: 拉面
Jake: Noodles.
Jake:有意思
Jake: Interesting.
Jake: 我们要干嘛
Jake: What are we going to do?
Tasha: 你觉得有意思就好
Tasha: As long as you find it interesting.
Jake: 我们要
Jake: We're going to...
Jake: 小贝
Jake: Little Bei?
Jake: 是吗
Jake: Really?
Jake: 肉松小贝
Jake: Meat floss Little Bei?
Jake: 还是
Jake: Or...
Jake:面团是干嘛的呀
Jake: What's the dough for?
Tasha: 都可
Tasha: Both are fine.
Tasha:做麻薯用的
Tasha: For making mochi.
Jake:做麻薯
Jake: Making mochi.
Tasha:肉公小贝还做吗今天
Tasha: Are we still making Meat floss Little Bei today?
Tasha:我在问你
Tasha: I'm asking you.
Tasha:我不是在
Tasha: I'm not...
Jake:呃 我们要 嗯麻薯是要单独的
Tasha:甜品
Tasha: Dessert.
Tasha:嗯
Tasha: Yeah.
Jake:可以做呀
Jake: We can make it.
Jake:做吧
Jake: Let's do it.
Jake: 好不好哈哈好
Jake: Shall we? Haha, okay.
Jake:嗯好
Jake: Uh, fine.
Jake:怎么十分不愿意的感觉
Jake: Why do you seem so unwilling?
Tasha: 没有没有
Tasha: No, no.
Tasha: 一切听您的指挥
Tasha: I'll follow your instructions.
Tasha: 加20克黄油
Tasha: Add 20 grams of butter.
Tasha: 切20克出来
Tasha: Cut out 20 grams.
Lucia: 我记得好像还有一把不过那把剪刀就是
Lucia: I remember there seems to be another pair, but those scissors...
Lucia: 就是 劲比较小
Lucia: They are just not very sharp.
Lucia: 如果它还在这的话
Lucia: If it's still here
Lucia: 可以大家轮流唱一首歌吗
Lucia: Can we all take turns singing a song?
Lucia: 还是大家合唱一首歌
Lucia: Or should we all sing a song together?
Alice:大家伴奏合唱一首歌
Alice: Everyone can sing together with accompaniment
Lucia: 可以
Lucia: Sure
Katrina: 合唱很那个
Katrina: Singing together is kind of...
Lucia: solo
Lucia: Solo
Katrina: 有没有感觉大家都淡淡的
Katrina: Does anyone feel like everyone's a bit indifferent?
Katrina: 不是很想的激情的感觉
Katrina: Not really feeling the enthusiasm
Katrina: 主要是这样还主要是衣服还没租对吗
Katrina: Mainly because we haven't rented the right clothes, right?
Tasha: 嗯还好还没租
Katrina: 没事我们是因为没租才做的决定的
Katrina: It's okay, we made the decision because we didn't rent them
Tasha: 其实租的话也可
Tasha: Actually, renting is fine too
Tasha: 现在租也来得及
Tasha: We can still rent them now
Lucia: 主要这几天大家排的话
Lucia: Mainly because these days if we rehearse
Lucia: 一个不知道人齐不齐
Lucia: First, we don't know if everyone will be here
Katrina: 嗯 人也不一定
Katrina: Yeah, not everyone might be here
Katrina: 然后第二感觉时间上
Katrina: And second, it feels like the time is tight
Lucia: 对然后感觉时间上有点紧张
Lucia: Yeah, it feels like the time is a bit tight
Katrina: 我觉得可以剪成综艺了
Katrina: I think it could be edited into a variety show
Shure:  你们在做狗
Shure: You guys are making a dog
Shure:  哎对
Shure: Oh, right
Shure:  很棒
Shure: Very nice
Shure:  有点东西只能说
Shure: It's something, I can only say
Shure:  我靠好香啊
Shure: Wow, it smells so good
Shure:  还有烤地瓜
Shure: And roasted sweet potatoes
Shure:  对
Shure: Yeah
Tasha: 烤了你吃吗
Tasha: Will you eat it if I roast it?
Shure:  我草
Shure: Damn
Jake: 繁荣这经济繁荣
Jake: This is economic prosperity
Jake: 局部经济繁荣
Jake: Local economic prosperity
Tasha: 完了
Tasha: It's over
Shure:  烤糊了
Shure: It's burnt
Tasha: 我刚刚感觉不够熟
Tasha: I just felt it wasn't cooked enough
Tasha: 又烤了一会
Tasha: So I roasted it a bit longer
Tasha: 你要不拿出去吃
Tasha: Why don't you take it out and eat it
Shure:  我都看着好香
Shure: It looks so good to me
Shure:  虽然我平时不吃烤地瓜
Shure: Even though I don't usually eat roasted sweet potatoes
Shure:  但是饿了你知道吗
Shure: But I'm hungry, you know?
Shure:  呼呼呼哈哈哈
Shure: Hahaha
Tasha: 哈哈哈
Tasha: Hahaha
Shure:  来张纸来张纸
Shure: Give me a piece of paper, give me a piece of paper.
Shure:  我靠
Shure: Oh crap.
Tasha: 这个这个盒子放上面了
Tasha: This, this box is on top.
Jake: 我吃一个
Jake: I'll eat one.
Jake: 可以吃吗
Jake: Can we eat this?
Jake: 应该可以
Jake: It should be fine.
Shure:  好香啊我靠
Shure: Smells so good, oh crap.
Shure:  这皮他是不能吃
Shure: This skin is not edible.
Shure:  他酥了
Shure: It's crispy.
Tasha: 什么
Tasha: What?
Shure:  我说这皮都能吃
Shure: I said the skin is edible.
Shure:  感觉
Shure: Feels like.
Tasha: 是啊煮过了
Tasha: Yeah, it's cooked.
Jake: 我靠
Jake: Oh crap.
Shure:  我靠
Shure: Oh crap.
Jake:绝香
Jake: Absolutely fragrant.
Shure:  巨香
Shure: Super fragrant.
Shure:  我第一次
Shure: My first time.
Alice:烧烤摊上就是这种
Alice: It's like this at the BBQ stand.
Jake: 哦
Jake: Oh.
Jake: 干
Jake: Cheers.
Shure: 干一个
Shure: Cheers.
Shure:  干地瓜
Shure: Cheers with sweet potato.
Jake: 地瓜会自动翻译
Jake: Sweet potato will auto-translate.
Shure:  直接给我翻译成什么
Shure: What will it translate to?
Jake:groundmelon
Jake: Groundmelon.
Shure:  对哈哈哈
Shure: Right, hahaha.
Jake: 哈哈
Jake: Haha.
Jake: 来重金属摇滚
Jake: Let's play heavy metal.
Shure:  好
Shure: Okay.
Jake:有声
Jake: There's sound.
Jake:这不对呀这不对呀
Jake: This isn't right, this isn't right.
Jake: 是不是听不懂中文啊
Jake: Can't understand Chinese?
Jake: 哇只会pop吧
Jake: Wow, it only knows pop, huh?
Shure:  好pop呀
Shure: So pop.
Shure:  no style more her heavy metal
Shure: No style, more like heavy metal.
Jake: 谢彬竹玩嗨了
Jake: Xie Binzhu is having a blast.
Jake: 第一回玩吗
Jake: First time playing?
Shure:  是的
Shure: Yes.
Jake: 大家弹过钢琴
Jake: Has everyone played the piano?
Shure:  啊弹钢琴还不错
Shure: Ah, playing the piano is pretty good.
Shure:  我靠还给他化妆
Shure: Wow, even doing makeup for him.
Jake: 是是挺是挺可爱哎呦
Jake: Yes, yes, it's quite cute, oh my.
Alice:好小狗 over
Alice: Good little dog, over.
Jake: 嗯
Jake: Hmm.
Jake: 我专门睁大眼睛
Jake: I'm purposely widening my eyes.
Lucia: 嗯
Lucia: Hmm.
Lucia: 因为不好不好打草稿
Lucia: Because it's hard to draft.
Jake: 还有大眼睛
Jake: And big eyes.
Jake: 噢
Jake: Oh.
Lucia: 所以就使用那个表情
Lucia: So just use that expression.
Lucia: 表情包模式
Lucia: Emoticon mode.
Jake: 他不会
Jake: He can't do it.
Jake: 你得给他歌词
Jake: You need to give him the lyrics.
Tasha: 杨老师最需要你的时候来了
Tasha: Jake, this is when we need you the most.
Tasha: 好了你可以把地瓜放下了
Tasha: Okay, you can put the sweet potato down now.
Jake: 我杵哪了
Jake: Where was I standing?
Jake: 我杵这了
Jake: I was standing here.
Shure:  他们说有可能是
Shure: They said it could be...
Shure:  这是一个引子啊
Shure: This could be a lead-in.
Tasha: 你带吧我手上有水
Tasha: You take it, my hands are wet.
Shure:  有可能是个引子哦
Shure: It could be a lead-in, oh.
Jake: 一个引子
Jake: A lead-in.
Shure:  让AI写我是草履虫和我
Shure: Let AI write "I am a paramecium and me".
Jake: 就是大伙可以给词他他词写的不行
Jake: So everyone can give lyrics, his lyrics aren't good.
Jake: 如果觉得你觉得怎么样
Jake: If you think, what do you think?
Shure:  还行
Shure: It's okay.
Jake:确实还行
Jake: It's indeed okay.
Shure:  很含糊哇哈哈哈这个节奏
Shure: Very vague, hahaha, this rhythm.
Katrina: 完咯
Katrina: It's over.
Jake: 哈哈哈完了
Jake: Hahaha, it's over.
Jake: 人机大战
Jake: Man vs. machine battle.
Shure: 我败下一程居然
Shure: I actually lost a round.
Tasha: 好看
Tasha: Nice.
Alice: 第一
Alice: First place.
Tasha:第一
Tasha: First place.
Shure: 巨好吃
Shure: Super delicious.
Katrina: 哇搅不动了
Katrina: Wow, I can't stir it anymore.
Jake: 我要干什么
Jake: What should I do now?
Jake: 啊我要搅和吗
Jake: Ah, should I mix it?
Tasha: 把它们揉在一起
Tasha: Knead them together.
Jake: 哎呦这
Jake: Oh, this...
Lucia: 这边出标了
Lucia: It's marked over here.
Jake: 哎呦好烫啊
Jake: Oh, it's so hot!
Tasha: 这还烫啊
Tasha: This is hot?
Tasha: 已经凉了好久了
Tasha: It's been cooling for a while.
Shure:  我输给AI了我靠
Shure: I lost to AI, damn it.
Shure:  确实
Shure: Indeed.
Jake:哈哈哈但是没有记忆点
Jake: Haha, but there's no memory point.
Jake: 我觉得对
Jake: I think so.
Jake: AI他这没
Jake: AI doesn't have this.
Jake: 哎呀我靠好烫啊
Jake: Oh my, it's so hot!
Tasha: 不好意思要不你脱下来吧
Tasha: Sorry, maybe you should take it off.
Jake: 哎呀
Jake: Oh my.
Tasha: 我以为已经过了好久了
Tasha: I thought it had been a long time.
Tasha: 那那等会你再来搅
Tasha: Then, you can mix it later.
Shure:  这就非常草东味你知道吗
Shure: This has a very Caodong flavor, you know?
Tasha: 怎么办
Tasha: What should we do?
Tasha: 行
Tasha: Okay.
Shure: 就是那个中间那个嘣嘣嘣嘣
Shure: It's like that part in the middle, boom boom boom.
Tasha: 等会在来搅吧
Tasha: Let's mix it later.
Jake:好
Jake: Okay.
Jake:啊好烫啊
Jake: Ah, it's so hot.
Shure:  你可以拿这个
Shure: You can use this.
Jake:哎呀你看一下手机怎么回事
Jake: Oh, check the phone, what's going on?
Shure:  我刚刚那个纸杯
Shure: I just used that paper cup.
Alice:应该是没怎么干了
Alice: It probably didn't dry much.
Shure:  拿它这么挤的
Shure: Squeeze it like this.
Jake: 呃不算挤
Jake: Uh, it's not squeezing.
Jake: 不挤不挤
Jake: Not squeezing, not squeezing.
Alice:我都走路上了吗
Alice: Am I on the way?
Alice: 应该怎么最后没有
Alice: Shouldn't it be, why didn't it...
Tasha: 吃吗
Tasha: Want to eat?
Jake: 啊也没有interaction
Jake: Ah, there's no interaction either.
Tasha:最后一个
Tasha: The last one.
Nicous: 我吃一半 谢谢
Nicous: I'll eat half, thanks.
Shure:  对这个间奏还不错
Shure: Yeah, this interlude is pretty good.
Jake: 没关系拿过来直接用
Jake: It's okay, just use it directly.
Shure:  这才是happy metal
Shure: This is true happy metal.
Shure:  但这这没词
Shure: But there's no lyrics here.
Jake: 没词
Jake: No lyrics.
Jake: 他这写词很沙雕的
Jake: His lyrics are pretty silly.
Tasha:我还要不要在报备
Tasha: Should I still report this?
Jake: 呃
Jake: Uh...
Jake: 我看一下他是是没空间了还是什么
Jake: Let me check if it's out of space or something.
Alice: 应该录了有快3个小时了
Alice: It's been recording for almost 3 hours.
Lucia:哎我的还在亮着吗
Lucia: Hey, is mine still on?
Alice: 我做小狗之前还有40多个G
Alice: I had over 40GB before I started the puppy project.
Jake: 嗯
Jake: Hmm.
Jake: 啥意思呢
Jake: What does that mean?
Jake: 我刷一下刷
Jake: Let me refresh it.
Jake: 把那个他的Wei page直接copy过来
Jake: Just copy his Wei page directly.
Jake: 就给写了一个
Jake: Just write it like that.
Shure:  这个才对
Shure: That's correct.
Shure:  你刚刚旺仔中间加个分号了
Shure: You added a semicolon in the middle of Wangzai.
Shure:  加个分号才才能
Shure: Adding a semicolon allows...
Shure:  就是识别下一个
Shure: ...it to recognize the next one.
Alice: 录了因为我在
Alice: It's recorded because I...
Alice:做小狗之前
Alice: ...before I started the puppy project.
Alice:我之前还有只有40多个g
Alice: I had over 40GB before.
Lucia: 随便录一个
Lucia: Just record anything.
Lucia: 最后还半个小时
Lucia: We have half an hour left.
Jake: 什什么情况
Jake: What's going on?
Jake: 什么情况
Jake: What's happening?
Jake: 笑什么
Jake: What's so funny?
Jake: 我也江苏人
Jake: I'm also from Jiangsu.
Jake: 但是我是很我
Jake: But I'm really...
Jake: 我那时候还是病题作文
Jake: Back then, I had to write prompted essays.
Jake: 我我那时候还命题作文
Jake: I had to write prompted essays back then.
Shure:  他没有
Shure: He didn't...
Shure:  没有
Shure: He didn't.
Shure:  哦你们只选两科
Shure: Oh, you guys only chose two subjects.
Jake: 对当初就是我
Jake: Yeah, back then I...
Tasha:我我
Tasha: I-I...
Tasha: 我也是巫师
Tasha: I'm also a wizard.
Katrina: 我生物当时
Katrina: For biology, I...
Katrina: 五个选择题四四个不确定那个定哪一家
Katrina: I was unsure about four out of five multiple choice questions.
Shure:  啊
Shure: Ah.
Katrina: 如果你一直看他一直给你推这个
Katrina: If you keep watching, it'll keep pushing this to you.
Katrina: 但是他那个很明显就是这个
Katrina: But it's very obvious that this...
Katrina: 出题人是支持这个现象的
Katrina: The question writer supports this phenomenon.
Katrina: 但是大家可以通过这种推荐的
Katrina: But through these recommendations,
Katrina:  13还是可以就是交到志周到合的朋友
Katrina: 13 people can still make like-minded friends.
Katrina: 但是我的关健词完全相同
Katrina: But my keywords are exactly the same.
Katrina: 只有半个小时
Katrina: Only half an hour.
Katrina: 1字未动写了一偏小说
Katrina: Not a single word written, ended up with a novel.
Katrina: 哈
Katrina: Haha.
Shure:  我奔着北欧来的
Shure: I came for Northern Europe.
Shure:  闹呢
Shure: Are you kidding me?
Shure:  我钱夹里当时放了两张照片
Shure: I had two photos in my wallet back then.
Shure:  一张老番茄一张何同学
Shure: One of Old Tomato and one of He Tongxue.
Shure:  差太多了
Shure: There's a huge difference.
Shure:  人家他妈是复旦
Shure: His mom is from Fudan University.
Katrina: 你们那个北邮分是不是比985高
Katrina: Your Beiyou score is higher than 985, right?
Shure:  比比好多985分高
Shure: Much higher than many 985 scores.
Katrina: 那你有没有后悔
Katrina: Do you regret it?
Shure:  不后悔
Shure: No regrets.
Shure:  我无所谓
Shure: I don't care.
Katrina: 你报志愿的时候
Katrina: When you applied for the schools...
Tasha: 套盒误拆
Tasha: The box was accidentally opened.
Jake: 能录吧这个啊
Jake: Can this be recorded?
Jake: 能录吧哈哈哈
Jake: Can this be recorded? Hahaha.
Jake: 没有
Jake: No.
Jake: 这一下午都没有
Jake: Not at all this afternoon.
Jake: 应该是不知道为什么可能是崩掉了
Jake: Probably crashed for some reason.
Jake: 没关系吧
Jake: It's okay, right?
Jake: 可以你对你可以对没关系
Jake: It's fine, you can, it's fine.
Jake: 来来写一首特朗普之歌
Jake: Come on, let's write a Trump song.
Shure:  别别别
Shure: No, no, no.
Shure:  哎我们来命题作文battle吧
Shure: Hey, let's have an essay battle.
Shure:  大家随便出个题
Shure: Anyone can give a topic.
Shure:  然后让他写和让我写
Shure: Then let him write and let me write.
Shure:  看看哪个更牛逼
Shure: Let's see who's better.
Jake: 那出个题
Jake: Then give a topic.
Shure:  来出个题
Shure: Come on, give a topic.
Shure:  就随便说
Shure: Just say anything.
Jake:谢彬竹之歌吧
Jake: Xie Binzhu's song.
Jake: 要不就哈哈哈
Jake: Or just hahaha.
Shure:  他不AI不知道谢彬竹是什么东西
Shure: He doesn't know what Xie Binzhu is.
Jake: 没关系没关系
Jake: It's okay, it's okay.
Jake: 我也给他形容一下
Jake: Let me describe it to him.
Jake: 谢彬竹是一个什么什么什么啊
Jake: What kind of person is Xie Binzhu?
Nicous: 谢彬竹是一个被吃掉会主动说谢谢的人
Nicous: Xie Binzhu is the kind of person who would thank you if you ate him.
Shure:  哈哈哈哈哈哈哈
Shure: Hahahahaha!
Jake: 你你这像是叫什么
Jake: You, you sound like...
Jake: 以前考状元的那种电视
Jake: one of those TV shows about the top scholars.
Jake: 哈哈哈
Jake: Hahaha.
Shure:  我们这样
Shure: How about we...
Shure:  随便拿个什么物品之类的当命题
Shure: Just pick any object as the topic?
Jake: 好也可以
Jake: Sure, that works too.
Shure:  可以吧
Shure: Is that okay?
Jake:北冰洋吧
Jake: How about Arctic Ocean?
Shure:  北冰洋
Shure: Arctic Ocean.
Jake: 北冰北冰洋
Jake: Arctic Arctic Ocean.
Jake: 北冰洋的什么
Jake: Arctic Ocean's what?
Jake: 唇唇膏
Jake: Lip balm.
Shure:  北冰洋的熊猫
Shure: Arctic Ocean's panda.
Jake: 北冰洋的熊猫
Jake: Arctic Ocean's panda.
Jake: DK音乐
Jake: DK music.
Jake: 对对
Jake: Yeah, yeah.
Shure: 北冰洋的熊猫是吗
Shure: Arctic Ocean's panda, right?
Jake: style
Jake: Style.
Shure: style你随便
Shure: Style, whatever you want.
Jake:我我随便
Jake: Me, me, whatever.
Lucia: 这个肚子是不是该给它减掉呢
Lucia: Should we get rid of this belly?
Jake: 喂
Jake: Hello?
Jake: 喂哎呦我去啊
Jake: Hello, oh my gosh.
Jake: 你好呵呵你好你好
Jake: Hi, haha, hello, hello.
Jake: 来了来了来了来了
Jake: Coming, coming, coming, coming.
Shure:  哎帮帮把把把着一下扶一下
Shure: Hey, help, help, hold it, support it.
Jake: 帮我帮我敲敲吧啊
Jake: Help me, help me knock it, yeah.
Shure:  你别让他happy metal就泡吧就好了
Shure: Don't let him do happy metal, just chill.
Shure:  你或者你不指定style你直接就是
Shure: Or don't specify the style, just...
Lucia: 哇好可爱你这腮红好心动啊
Lucia: Wow, so cute, your blush is so charming.
Shure:  不用他他会自动也也也生成一个style
Shure: No need, he'll automatically create a style.
Alice: 哈哈哈
Alice: Hahaha.
Lucia: 套装误拆
Lucia: Don't disassemble the set.
Lucia: 我还给他剪了个尾巴
Lucia: I even cut a tail for him.
Shure:  他
Shure: He...
Shure:  啊
Shure: Ah
Jake: 要不走上去
Jake: How about we walk up?
Jake: 帮我拿一下吧
Jake: Help me hold this.
Jake: 来谢谢你啊
Jake: Thanks a lot.
Jake: 上来吃饭吧
Jake: Come up and eat.
Shure:  不行
Shure: No way.
Tasha: 吃完就去把面团揉了吧
Tasha: After eating, let's knead the dough.
Jake: 哎好
Jake: Alright.
Jake: 这个温度应该合适
Jake: The temperature should be good.
Jake: 永不什么
Jake: Never what?
Shure: 前面得给我立个二维码
Shure: You need to set up a QR code for me in the front.
Shure:  好吧哈哈哈
Shure: Alright, haha.
Jake: 李先生面馆驻唱
Jake: Singing at Mr. Li's noodle shop.
Shure:  别抬了抬了还需好吃的
Shure: Don't lift it, it needs to be delicious.
Jake: 哎不对 不抬了
Jake: No, don't lift it.
Shure:  这个反正是一人一份
Shure: Anyway, everyone gets one portion.
Shure:  这种有个座吃就行
Shure: As long as you have a seat to eat, it's fine.
Jake: 哎对
Jake: Yeah.
Jake: 蹲着吃都行
Jake: Even squatting to eat is fine.
Shure:  对
Shure: Right.
Shure:  赶早好吧
Shure: Early bird, okay.
Shure:  开始黑武汉人了
Shure: Starting to make fun of Wuhan people.
Nicous: 我靠这是什么东西啊
Nicous: What the heck is this?
Shure:  对套餐里的小菜
Shure: It's the side dish in the set meal.
Nicous: 这么叼啊
Nicous: So fancy?
Shure:  谁的番茄面
Shure: Whose tomato noodles?
Tasha: 我的
Tasha: Mine.
Shure:  好哦
Shure: Okay.
Tasha: 好哦
Tasha: Okay.
Tasha: 番茄面应该不要米饭
Tasha: Tomato noodles shouldn't come with rice.
Nicous: 我的
Nicous: Mine.
Shure:  还有安格斯肥牛面
Shure: Also, there's Angus beef noodles.
Shure:  招牌牛肉面
Shure: Signature beef noodles.
Shure:  对我的没错
Shure: Yes, that's mine.
Lucia: 这是谁的面啊
Lucia: Whose noodles are these?
Shure: 这是
Shure: These are...
Jake:这我的
Jake: These are mine.
Shure:  每人三个
Shure: Everyone gets three.
Shure:  这个是吗
Shure: Is this one?
Shure:  我不知道反正是咚不咚
Shure: I don't know, anyway it's ding or not ding.
Shure:  咚不咚咚咚
Tasha: 这有什么这有什么
Nicous: 这是他们的
Jake: 我操哈哈哈
Jake: 你服了我操
Shure:  臭二次元滚出去
Jake: 哼这不行了
Jake: 来一个
Jake: 考虑啊你
Shure:  你是不是私宅
Shure:  真恶心啊
Shure:  让人坐不下
Tasha: 那我是什么
Shure:  要不我坐小孩那桌去吧
Tasha: 我是
Tasha: 海带丝和
Shure: 好吧
Shure:  北冰洋的熊猫
Shure:  要加点香菜吗
Lucia: 其实我可以加
Lucia: 哈哈
Alice:他是不是没给米饭
Alice: Did he forget the rice?
Lucia: 这个米饭哦
Lucia: This rice, huh?
Alice: 这是我的吗
Alice: Is this mine?
Shure:  这一生吃的最多的面
Shure: The noodles I've eaten the most in my life
Shure:  就是李先生牛肉面
Shure: are Mr. Lee's beef noodles.
Shure:  你呢
Shure: How about you?
Katrina: 他还在很认真的唱这首歌
Katrina: He's still seriously singing this song.
Shure: 他妈的我是要吃饭
Shure: Damn it, I'm trying to eat.
Shure: 你等我吃饭完
Shure: Wait for me to finish eating.
Shure:  够撕一下的
Shure: Give it a break.
Jake:还起了个陶喆曲风
Jake: He even adopted a David Tao style.
Katrina: 谁
Katrina: Who?
Shure:  这确实有点陶喆那味味
Shure: It does have a bit of that David Tao vibe.
Jake: 我应该我应该搞什么呀
Jake: What should I be doing?
Shure:  搞一个不不不
Shure: Do this, no, no, no,
Shure:  把这个端拿起来
Shure: pick up this end.
Shure:  然后把它倒到那个下面汤里面
Shure: Then pour it into the soup below.
Jake: 我靠这外卖这讲究
Jake: Wow, this takeout is fancy.
Shure:  这是开到美美国加州的牛肉面
Shure: This is beef noodles from California, USA.
Alice: 谁的鸡没拿
Shure:  我的鸡
Alice:谁的鸡
Shure:  这是我点的鸡吗
Shure:  拿个垫直接坐地下就好
Shure:  完了没垫
Jake:咱们
Shure:  卧槽哈哈哈哈哈哈
Jake: 这个应该过去
Lucia: 我已经全倒进去了
Alice: 这是你的吧
Tasha: 嗯
Alice: 这里面还有这个呢
Lucia: 啊我撒了一个
Alice: 你吃这个吗
Tasha: 你可以撒
Tasha: 哦
Tasha: 对你不用撒
Alice:不是我逗你呢
Alice: 这有葱和香菜
Alice: There’s some scallions and cilantro here.
Alice: 有人要吗
Alice: Anyone want some?
Alice: 还有好几包呢
Alice: There's still a few packs left.
Alice: 那边要吗
Alice: How about over there?
Jake: 来个李师傅牛肉面吧
Jake: Let's get some Master Li's beef noodles.
Shure:  周杰伦的风格
Shure: Jay Chou's style.
Jake: 不好周杰伦这个是敏感词
Jake: No good, mentioning Jay Chou is a sensitive topic.
Alice: 什么
Alice: What?
Jake: 不行这感觉太贵了
Jake: Nope, this feels too expensive.
Jake: 陶喆不够贵
Jake: David Tao isn't pricey enough.
Shure:  现在又要用真爱
Shure: Now we need to use "True Love" again.
Lucia: 你说眼镜吗
Lucia: You mean the glasses?
Lucia: 他现在没有灯亮着
Lucia: They aren't lighting up right now.
Lucia: 我现在能按长按这个电脑
Lucia: I can hold down this computer now.
Lucia: 不会充电宝没电了
Lucia: Could the power bank be out of charge?
Lucia: 充电宝没电了
Lucia: The power bank is out of charge.
Lucia: 你找到了
Lucia: You found it.